what do you think about with Zuckerberg
getting involved in the UFC and what
he's doing because that when the video
came out with Zuck I don't I mean those
that video is a real video he didn't
look like a you know sometimes people
show their videos like they're boxing or
training you're like yeah you shouldn't
have put that up like Stephen A Smith
one time put up a video unboxing yeah
and I hope he was just trolling actually
everybody on Twitter went after him but
when Mark put it up you're like you know
what those kicks are real kids yeah he
just doesn't move too bad at all man
zuck's got some hands and some kicks you
know who else that Wiz Khalifa you ever
seen Wiz Khalifa Wiz Khalifa or I don't
know if you can scrap out I mean he can
hit pads
yeah he's a tall lanky dude yeah like
you know when you when you just watch
guys so you Norm used to seeing
Zuckerberg like in his you know Facebook
attire or whatever all of a sudden he's
you know throwing on gloves and hitting
pads and throwing knees and kicks and
low leg kicks yeah so how is he getting
involved you mean just kind of watching
or or is there something he wants to do
more with it you think there's I I don't
know I'd be interested to see what
Dana's perspective would be on on that
actually I don't know so what what is
the story he's been he's been kind of
invited to these private showings that's
not a private showing it was at the UFC
Apex which is somewhat private because I
think it only holds maybe 500 people or
so and you can go you can go I think you
can buy a table and have a couple people
with you and watch the fights yeah
um it's by no means a private event but
it's definitely not a you know a arena
show but there was reports that came out
because there was a girl named Mackenzie
Dern who I think was either the the main
event or the co-main event I think it
was the main event who said that
Zuckerberg rented out the whole Apex out
of the show which I think turned out to
be not true oh really well let me tell
you allegedly let me tell you something
Michael Dana White number one promoter
out there in the world when you're
talking about hype and Showmanship and
just Pizzazz I'm thinking Mark
Zuckerberg guys
definitely not a human robot
yeah I just got canceled yeah but you
know what you know what the to me you
know he went on Joe Joe Rogan and the
interview came out you know some stuff
that he said with FBI and all this other
stuff and then he's out there doing
stuff I think a part of him is like look
man I'm worth a hundred billion dollars
but I'm living my life as well and I got
interest and I'm doing what I'm doing
and I don't know I like it I like seeing
what he's doing I like the fact that
he's out there doing what he's doing in
the water I like the fact that you're
here if he's not an alien listen if
you've ever seen the video where he
smokes Meats for an hour he's like yeah
I'm smoking some meat smoking some ribs
smoking like just it's an hour if I'm
talking about how he says no no the
weirdest strangest thing weirdest is him
I guarantee one of you two of you
probably seen it he's testifying in
front of Congress about the privacy
issues of Facebook and the memes of him
being a robot because he's sitting like
this Mike and I'm not joking if you can
pull up he it's like almost a robot he
goes
I have to drink this now it was the
weirdest drinking of water I've ever
seen on my life but but he also he also
had a mic drop moment which one was it
when they said so
he so Mark uh how do you guys make money
okay we sell ads
and the guy's like oh okay and he goes
to the next person you don't remember
this whole mic uh when he says we sell
ads like why do you think we make money
like we have nothing else to sell our
Lottery is selling ads and the guy had
nothing back to say to him by the way
you know how much money he's lost this
year his net worth has dropped 61
billion dollars
what do you think he's worth now
to sell them five bucks I think he may
like need some money he's still worth
100 billion or not he's still probably
worth 40 billion he's probably the word
Pat I say this all the time
Facebook stock has gone down that much
or what yeah Facebook stock well a lot a
lot of the tech companies have taken
this week the great news when Elon Musk
announced that he's buying them all the
tech stocks went to the roof Twitter
blew up and it brought everybody else up
Facebook went up everybody went up this
week but uh uh uh Facebook's taking a
hit I think they they decide they
started a
news site like sub stack and they just
shut it down yesterday or today they
just shut down substack uh and meta some
stuff is going on with them that they're
trying to re-strategize and what to do
with the product but uh you know he's uh
he's he's definitely got a few
challenges ahead of him but you know his
product the product that he has is not
the product that it once was the moment
they changed the app of the advertising
side where it no longer kept track of
how you did advertising before and then
have to refresh because yeah that's even
that yeah Advertiser that changed the
game in a big way it messed with
everybody's ability to to track
everything
yeah exactly you know that was the whole
model about it though the whole thing
that was very appealing was you know if
I spend 100 Grand I can retarget the
people now I gotta start from scratch
again yeah unless that was a PR was
there was there some kind of privacy
issue deal going that's what it was
that's always the whole thing okay so
they did it from the Privacy crazy you
know conspiracy question just throwing
it out there in the last 24 months
Zuckerberg you know Mr Robot himself
when before they changed Facebook to
meta right the epitome of joined the
matter you seen that commercial where he
did it was like you can come into the
metaverse and have an avatar
it was the most robotic commercial thing
ever but you know basically and then
since then
everything with meta nfts cryptos
obviously [ __ ] the bed yeah do you think
someone pulled him aside and was like
listen bro people legitimately think
you're a cyborg or a robot like straight
up like they actually think that
start doing some UFC stuff start cooking
some Meats get out there and start
surfing and maybe don't put so much
sunscreen in your face whatever just go
be a human yeah do you think someone
actually said that to him
I I don't know I I think
listen I think when you make money
and then you have Fu money times a
hundred like you know a few money is
what anything above
let's just say 100 million dollars got a
few money you gotta be above 165. yeah
you could lose it let me tell you a
couple ways that goes real quick all
right listen hey have you seen the price
of fuel you go from Europe to Vegas
[Laughter]
so you're saying when you got [ __ ]
money you know what I'm saying is I'm
saying do the guys how old is the guy
now is he 38 is he Thirty late 30s early
38 years old it's kind of like I want to
live a life this is what I want to do
bro like leave me alone bro I just build
a company I compete I got a big I'm rich
yes I got money and I'm pretty powerful
I still want to live a life I don't want
to be just this billionaire I want to
live my life I think there's a part of
it that's just more than life if you
constantly have to act for how the World
Views you dude that's a myth you're a
slave to the world it's not a good life
it doesn't matter how much money they
give you if you constantly like by the
way you know what's been happening that
you're seeing
is I think Elon started this trend I
fully believe it on started this trend
because if you think about Elon Bezos
Zuck which one of them enjoys life the
most okay but that wasn't the case for
the longest time because he wasn't he
was so mechanical and he was so much
about Ben finally he's like listen man
I'm I'm freaking here's who I am I'm the
real guy from Iron Man and he's in the
movie like oh [ __ ] that's funny yeah
he's got a great senior here oh so this
guy's got a lighter side to him he's not
just a genius you know I'm going through
the space type of guy and then he starts
trolling and he's taking shots at uh our
President Joe Biden and then Bezos is
like well why are people liking him more
than me maybe I can say something to Joe
Biden then Bezos did and then now Zuck
is coming out so I think what's happened
with all these guys is you know elon's
trying to say to these guys you can be
the richest man on the planet but you
still got to live your life and enjoy
yourself because he's gonna die
eventually ain't gonna live forever so
yeah I think they're all kind of
learning from each other like whatever
space you're in you're gonna look get
another Pacesetter in your world to see
what they're doing in the Pacesetter in
this world is musk today and they're
kind of following his lead now I really
agree here's a real question here's a
real question
say Dana's able to pull this fight off
Jake Paul Bezos and Zuck
the biggest pay-per-view of all time for
sure
it tops that list
they sent one tweet next thing you know
paper review
29.7 million buys you know so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you